miss Jin knows faster faster but that is
why Jennifer was just named one of 20 19
best-dressed by Vanity Fair I always
have fun with fashion J Lo's brand of
sexy chic is what landed her on the list
maybe she'd like this look better from
RiRi who's also on the list your
favorite fashion moment that you've had
shoot I don't know if I should say that
because I was kind of naked there are
days where you can look perfect with the
perfect hair and makeup and perfect
wardrobe but there will be days when you
don't and that's fine too
Priyanka Chopra made the cut for the
first time what she wants to be buried
in diamonds for crazy rich asian star
Jimmy Chan it's the fuchsia Valentino
she wore to the Oscars there are 40
style icons in all from Keanu's polished
runs look and signature hair toss to
Brad in a tuxedo slave to fashion baby
I'm a slave to fashion fierce
fashionista celine dion tells the mag
her new home in las vegas is under
construction and I treated myself to a
playground two stories of archives for
all my clothes shoes belts I kept every
my kids are even if their boys are into
fashion they're into characters they're
into everything
the Beckham family's on the list thanks
to their fashion savvy insta game they
have over 100 million followers combined
then there's the power couples Jason
Momoa and Lisa Bonet Gabrielle Union and
Dwyane Wade and of course
[Applause]
[Music]